and we do start with that developing  story in southern california here is a  live look at a  devastating car crash near el centro  which is a couple hundred miles east of  san diego that  sv right there that ford california  highway patrol says there were 27 people  in that suv and it was hit by the  tractor-trailer you see on the right of  your screen  chp california highway patrol says at  least 13  people are dead and in fact troopers  there say that suv  stopped at an intersection then drove  directly into the path  of that semi truck again the latest  numbers 13 people dead in that suv that  had 27 people inside  we will continue to follow the situation  all throughout the day just a tragic  situation there